[Music]
elisa
is with us in atlanta hi elisa how are
you
hi dave hi christy i'm doing good how
are you guys great how can we help um
so my husband and i have been following
your plan
for a while but we in the last
year or two here have become
self-employed and we've really had an
income
problem trying to keep uh cash flow
going so even making progress on paying
off the debt has been
difficult um we're in a situation right
now
where we've had some medical bills come
up that have increased our debt we also
uh didn't because of the cash flow
issues didn't have enough saved up
for taxes uh for 2020 so
we you know set up a payment plan with
the irs and all that want to get that
out of the way
um but we're also trying to make sure we
save up taxes
for the coming year um
properly and i know that you say
like baby step zero is basically like
getting
uh current on all your bills and not
going to into any more debt and that
sort of thing
so i've been just a little
confused on what order i should be
attacking these things in because these
medical bills are technically current
um but we also don't have the money to
pay them right now we had like a couple
of emergency room businesses
so what's going on with your business
what do you what do you both do and what
do you make
um my husband uh has a video production
business right now he's primarily doing
some video editing
freelance work as that and then i
have a proofreading freelance you have a
what freelance
proofreading proofread
okay and what do y'all make combined
uh last year
our uh income on our taxes was
uh oh crud i just forgot i think it was
about
32 000 um or probably
less than that yeah what what did you do
sorry how many kids do you think how
many kids do you have
it's just the two of us okay what did
you do before this you said you
recently became self-employed what did
y'all used to do
and what's the story there uh
so last year actually in the middle of
the pandemic my husband launched his
video production
business and that was a good move
because before that he was working
a pretty low paying server job
i was a full-time employee as a
proofreader and then i
i've done like some over each driving
and stuff since then and
and one other w-2 job for a few months
this year but that ended up not working
out
yeah you know what i'm calling it back
and forth i'm calling bs
your husband made more as a server than
he did in the video business
it was not a good it was not a good it
was not a good thing it was a good thing
in that servers disappeared
during covid but in terms of he
launched into he didn't exactly go make
a fortune you guys are living up
i think your 32 thousands wrong all
you've told me in the first five minutes
you've been on the air is how
like six different times is how you guys
have absolutely no money
i think you're living below the poverty
level and y'all are running around
calling this a successful business it's
not
it's failed you need to get jobs i i
don't know
here's what i'm confused about alisa is
what you just told me in terms of your
you know y'all went through the debts
and getting your bills current all that
what i hear though
is you sound okay with the amount of
money you all make and you don't make
enough money
why are y'all not out there getting
second and third jobs and getting your
income up
well i actually no like we're
aware that we're struggling and we need
more money i've been working
i think you are what i can't figure out
for you i'm getting
okay um i will say
that the numbers have been going up the
last few months significantly where
we're looking at we're looking at him
bringing in
bringing home like two thousand dollars
at least
this month uh which is a significant
increase and it's been trajectoring
upward um are you all charging enough
uh say that again are you are
each of you charging enough is it a lack
of uh
not the right pricing or do you not have
enough clients or both do you know what
those
what the source of the income revenue
problem is
uh the primary problem has been
lack of clients uh what the clients he
has
right now are definitely paying
appropriate amounts for the video
editing work he's doing
okay yeah he's not working much
he has been the last couple months we
had a lot of issues with like the first
six months this year
yeah but but like i mean two thousand
bucks video editing in a month
he's not working much well and my other
thing though at least like okay so
today's point about like what we're both
saying about this
income issue is like starting a video
production business
you can do video editing almost anytime
you want
you can serve at a restaurant lots of
different options of shifts and hours
i don't know why he's not doing both
video editing on the side
working as many hours as he can as a
server he could double his income right
there
if he had kept the server job yeah that
i agree
so here's what i'm hearing and you you
can correct me what you're saying
you can you can go you can go do
whatever you want to at least but here's
what i'm hearing
okay he launched a video business and he
loves to do the video work and he's good
at
the video work itself he is not
good at marketing and getting new
clients and he's not
good at running a business because he's
starving to death
and you're starving to death with him
meanwhile you're over here trying to
plug up the 42 holes in this boat with
only two fingers
and you're working like three different
jobs while he's working one
that's not working it that's not working
out so
if i were to come into your alls lives
what i would tell
him to do today he needs to do
one of two things he either needs to go
get a job in the video business
and make four times what he's making now
working for somebody else
that knows how to go get clients and
then builds him out as an editor or as a
producer or as
behind the camera or whatever he's good
at um or
until he gets uh or if he's gonna keep
doing this
he needs to get three side jobs in
addition to this and i want him working
80 hours a week
starting now with uber with deliver
with delivering pizzas with working uh
at the restaurant serving so that he can
keep his video business alive
so his family can stay alive while he
runs his video business and learns how
to be a marketer
and learns how to learns his business
acumen to run his business
because he's killing you he's killing
you sitting on his butt
listen the way these ducks land on your
plate cooked
is you have to go leave your house and
shoot them
and then you have to pluck them and then
you cook them
but they don't fly in the door and land
on the plate
in business you have to go get them and
he hasn't developed that skill yet he's
not a bad guy
he's an artist and he's probably very
good at his craft and he's probably not
lazy he's just not got a good game plan
right now he's got to go
duck hunting meanwhile he needs to go
make some freaking money
and this is why we tell you all we tell
you all this all the time not just you
alisa i mean every one of you listening
that's why we tell you
start your new business idea on this
side
build it up in addition to your
full-time income because nothing will
kill your dream
like not having any money and getting to
a place of desperation it takes the joy
right out of it
elisa if you will stay on the line i'm
gonna have kelly give you
a live stream ticket to our business
boutique conference you and your husband
can watch it together the business
principles supply regardless it will
give him
and you tons of tactical steps of what
to do
to market your individual businesses and
your services
in order to get more clients and make
more money
stay on the line kelly can give you that
and that will give you guys something to
to get started in this direction in
addition to everything else we're
telling you to do but
listen my wife has never been a wife in
39 years that wasn't supportive elisa
but she also her method of supporting
sometimes was to tell me the truth
and you're participating in delusion
with him the language you're using
the way you're taking up for this failed
business endeavor
it's a hobby it's you're starving to
death
he is not a success yet can he be
yes but not doing what he's been doing
for the last year and a half
and two thousand dollars you know you
make that in two weeks delivering pizza
you know so we're not successful yet
don't participate in that
so love him enough to walk with him
encourage him i think he can be a big
deal
but he ain't yet he's not even a little
deal yet